[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du skyco le
magazine qui vous raconte les aventures
économiques du territoire de 50 ans en
Yvelines pour cette édition nous sommes
au siège du groupe airway la Montigny le
Bretonneux cette PME est spécialisée
dans la fabrication de solutions
thermiques et climatiques elle conçoit
notamment des pompes à chaleur et dans
un contexte d'inflation sur l'énergie
elle amplifie sa stratégie pour
développer de nouvelles solutions
innovantes c'est ce que vous allez
découvrir dans ce 49e
nécessité de maîtriser la consommation
spécialiste de l'énergie et pouvoir
public se mobilise auprès des
entreprises basé à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux le groupe airwell
propose des solutions innovantes pour
maîtriser la consommation d'énergie une
activité de plus en plus en
développement une semaine
entreprise organisée par
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines du 21 au 25
novembre plusieurs rendez-vous se sont
tenus à destination des entreprises au
ski cube des réunions d'information dans
un contexte d'inflation sur les produits
énergétiques qui peuvent mettre en
difficulté le tissu économique alors
quels sont les aides proposées par les
pouvoirs publics quels sont les gestes
que doivent adopter les collaborateurs
en entreprise pour réduire leur
consommation d'énergie regardez ce
décryptage
[Musique]
vous avez de la porte entrepreneur sur
le territoire dirigeant des figurines
consulting et par ailleurs directeur du
club climat énergie de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
[Musique]
alors le club qui m'énerve maintenant
presque 10 ans c'est un écosystème
cofondé par 50 ans Yvelines et les
entreprises du territoire chargés de
proposer de réfléchir une sorte de sing
tank sur des solutions
contribuent à la transition écologique
et énergétique
aujourd'hui on fait face à un prix
vraiment très élevé de l'énergie je
pense que les entreprises ne sont pas
vraiment préparés aujourd'hui elles sont
plutôt en attitude de subir hors qu'elle
pourrait être proactive
c'est là les premières actions que nous
devons mener que les entreprises doivent
mener alors quand elles le peuvent
évidemment l'isolation des bâtiments et
les actions plus parfois plus simples
peut-être moins onéreuses le changement
de l'éclairage par le remplacer les
tubes fluorescents par des LED c'est
quand même assez significatif mettre des
capteurs qui sont pas forcément très
onéreux dans certaines salles de Rio qui
ne sont pas utilisées ça aussi
profitable pour bien sa consommation
d'énergie de la même manière les choses
qui sont relativement simple auxquelles
on ne pense pas c'est de privilégier
quand on peut le faire bien entendu les
collections via le wifi plutôt que les
4G ou 5G qui sont également plus
consommateurs
[Musique]
Anne failli directrice générale adjointe
en charge du développement économique et
du sport territoire à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
[Musique]
et 50 ans en Yvelines comme nous
l'avions fait pendant la mise en place
des mesures d'accompagnement lors de la
crise covid et aux côtés de son tissu
d'entreprise pour pouvoir les informer
les sensibiliser sur l'ensemble de
dispositifs des aides des appuis qui
peuvent être mobilisés pour accompagner
cette phase structurante pour leur
développement et leur croissance nous
avons édité un guide qui existe un
format papier et qui sera téléchargeable
et qui est téléchargeable sur le site
internet de l'agglomération qui regroupe
donc tous les dispositifs d'aide et les
mesures d'accompagnement pour les
entreprises évidemment dans ces moments
de crise c'est aussi des moments
d'opportunité pour faire évoluer à la
fois les process de fabrication pour
qu'ils soient qu'ils intègrent les
enjeux énergétiques d'un compagnons à la
fois les propriétaires et les et les
locataires dans
l'intégration de ces enjeux dans leur
performance énergétique
installer à 50 ans en Yvelines depuis
les années 70 d'abord à Guyancourt puis
depuis 2017 à Montigny-le-Bretonneux le
groupe airwell emploie 75 collaborateurs
cette société réalise plus de 50
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires à
travers 80 pays dans le monde
et pour parler de la stratégie du
développement de l'entreprise nous
sommes avec Laurent Rogel bonjour
bonjour enchanté
alors au vu de la du contexte actuel de
l'inflation comment évolue votre
activité comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
très fortement on est sur on est sur le
métier de l'offre de la rénovation
énergétique donc fabriquant historique
de pompe à chaleur
fabricant et développeurs de solutions
globales dans l'efficacité énergétique
donc on est sur une croissance d'environ
30 à 35% sur un marché qui croit déjà
lui d'une vingtaine de pour cent par an
et on arrive depuis déjà quelques années
à performer un petit peu plus que le
marché suite aux solutions innovantes
qu'on a pu développer depuis quelques
années on voit inflation réchauffement
climatique quelle solution vous proposez
face à ces problématiques là on est
clairement sur ces thèmes là on est sur
une volonté de partir du besoin du
client final de pas proposer les
solutions innovantes les plus innovantes
et les plus compliquées à installer qui
en deviennent des usines à SAV donc on
est vraiment dans l'approche solution
client final pour lui permettre
d'atteindre de manière réelle
l'efficacité énergétique donc on a des
solutions pour la pour la partie
résidentielle pour le marché des
particuliers et pour la partie TERT pour
le marché plus industriel autour du
marché du résidentiel et du particulier
on est sur une solution globale qui
intègre et une réponse à ses besoins de
chauffage de refroidit de
rafraîchissement d'eau chaude et un
apport en énergie via des panneaux
solaires photovoltaïques ou thermique et
aussi un apport en objet connecté en
data pour créer des scénarios
d'efficacité énergétique qui permettront
après de créer des algorithmes
apprenants d'efficacité énergétique donc
on est sur sur la volonté de proposer
une solution globale partant du principe
que l'efficacité ou la réduction des
consommations énergétiques ne pourront
venir que de l'ensemble que du système
que de l'écosystème est pas du produit
Pompe à Chaleur historique airwell voilà
qui est qui ne suffit pas à donner
l'efficacité réelle c'est efficace sur
un banc d'essai mais si vous voulez pour
le particulier ça soit efficace il faut
y intégrer un apport en énergie de la
data et du contrôle pour que l'ensemble
soit efficace vous l'avez dit
historiquement c'est la pompe à chaleur
comment c'est fait la transition
justement dans l'évolution de la société
pour aller vers les autres solutions
finalement pas forcément ça parce que
alors déjà nous on est un fabricant Hist
et puis après au niveau des forces
commerciales aussi c'est pas la même
chose de vendre un produit de vendre une
pompe à chaleur que de vendre un service
ou une solution donc de la formation
accompagner les accompagner nos
collaborateurs et notre réseau
d'installateurs de partenaires
distributeurs dans ces changements donc
on a dû pour cela même créer un centre
de formation et voilà académie pour
accompagner le changement de la filière
mais aussi en interne donc ça ça
nécessite beaucoup plus que simplement
rajouter une feuille dans un catalogue
c'est un vrai changement structurel
alors justement le gouvernement incite
aujourd'hui les entreprises à mettre en
place des plans sobriété énergétiques
auprès de leurs collaborateurs pour
participer à cette économie d'énergie
comment ça se passe chez vous qui êtes
pleinement engagé dans ce métier là tout
à fait alors c'est pas forcément le
cordonnier le mieux chaussé peut-être
mais parce qu'on essaie d'avoir un
niveau un petit peu en amont pour créer
quelque chose et être et s'engager sur
les résultats donc on a créé une offre
qu'on appelle easy une offre commerciale
avec des multiples partenaires qui
permet d'aller de l'audit énergétique à
un plan de recommolation et de sobriété
énergétique à la mise en place se passe
de ce de ce plan de recommandation par
l'installation des produits tout
financer sous forme de leasing
énergétique l'idée étant que le leasing
la mensualité de vos frais
d'investissement soit payés par
l'économie d'énergie générée par la mise
en place de ce système donc c'est assez
complexe il a fallu bien intégrer
plusieurs briques qui n'étaient pas les
nôtres donc on travaille Bureau Veritas
par exemple pour la partie audit on
travaille avec un partenaire pour la
partie borne de recharge de voiture on
travaille avec un autre partenaire pour
la partie éclairage parce que quand on
veut parler de rénovation globale il
faut avoir des expertise globale et on
ne peut pas tout faire on n'est pas
légitime à tout faire et on a donc à
travers à travers nos développements on
a voulu prouver l'efficacité réelle de
nos solutions donc le siège à 50 ans
Yvelines à Montigny
participera à partir de l'année
prochaine au championnats de France de
l'efficacité énergétique justement pour
en faire un bâtiment témoin et montrer
que nos solutions apportent de réel de
réels résultats
donc tout ça ça permet le fait de
participer à ce championnat de France
entre guillemets ça permet d'embarquer
aussi les équipes d'embarquer l'ensemble
de notre société d'abord dans des
changements de produits de conception
puis dans les changements comportement
comportementaux pardon qui permettront
après une amélioration continue parce
que c'est bien d'atteindre un objectif
de réduction mais après il faut il y a
toujours des points à gagner sur le
changement comportemental alors avant
d'aller rejoindre Alexandre NT1 votre
chef de produit qui va nous expliquer
justement les différentes solutions
rentrées dans les détails techniques un
dernier mot parce que en septembre
dernier votre entreprise est coté a été
introduit en bourse
cotation Euronext
comment pourquoi en fait pourquoi quelle
est la stratégie derrière cette
introduction en Bourse l'objectif était
de financer cette croissance de financer
ce développement donc on a des réussites
mais on a besoin de partenaires
financeurs pour nous accompagner donc
les trois objectifs majeurs de cette
introduction en Bourse était de
récupérer du financement et pouvoir
faire des levées de fonds pour trois
objectifs principaux donc une croissance
externe donc les réussites qu'on peut
avoir en métropole l'objectif étant de
de le dupliquer aussi sur d'autres pays
on est présent dans 80 pays donc l'idée
étant de faire des acquisitions ou
renforcer notre présence dans certains
marchés internationaux la deuxième
partie était d'accélérer encore un petit
peu notre expertise notre montée en
compétence autour des métiers de la data
l'intelligence artificielle les objets
connectés donc de vraiment recruter et
construire une plateforme R&D dédiée à
cette offre-là et à cette expertise là
et la troisième partie était de se
renforcer aussi sur ce qui va devenir un
élément clé de nos développements à
savoir le service on doit offre service
ciel exige un niveau de qualité de
service optimum et pour cela on a
l'obligation de prendre un peu plus la
main sur la partie maintenance et
services donc on a aussi des projets de
croissance externe à ce niveau là merci
Laurent Rogel c'est un plaisir merci à
vous rappelle que vous êtes le dirigeant
du groupe airwell et donc on va
rejoindre tout de suite Alexandre rente
qui nous expliquer justement les
solutions innovantes sur lesquelles vous
vous engagez actuellement
[Musique]
c'est un outil en cours de développement
au sein du groupe airway l'intelligence
artificielle et pour en parler nous
sommes avec Alexandre rente bonjour
[Musique]
alors comment est utilisé aujourd'hui
l'intelligence artificielle dans vos
solutions alors en fait c'est assez
simple on avait tendance à se focaliser
sur le produit
sachant qu'aujourd'hui tous les produits
sont plus ou moins efficaces on a
souhaité il agréger cette intelligence
artificielle afin d'optimiser la
consommation électrique du foyer
concrètement qu'est-ce que ça donne bon
qu'est-ce que ça donne aujourd'hui vous
savez qu'on propose des produits de
climatisation de chauffage ainsi que de
la production d'électricité via les
panneaux solaires donc l'objectif c'est
de faire communiquer environnement
ensemble et de pouvoir
en fonction en fait de la production
d'électricité des panneaux par exemple
actionner ou non certains systèmes
thermodynamiques afin d'optimiser la
consommation d'énergie et finalement ces
solutions participent à la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique tout à fait
l'objectif étant d'avoir un maximum
d'énergie renouvelable au sein de
l'Union européenne alors je disais
l'intelligence artificielle là vous êtes
en cours de développement mais vous
pensez déjà à l'étape d'après quelles
sont les réflexions en cours aujourd'hui
chez airwell de toute façon ce
développement va être sur du long terme
il va être en constante amélioration en
fait via différents algorithmes que nous
allons développer au fil des années donc
ce projet finalement n'a pas vraiment de
fin merci à Alexandra avec plaisir je
rappelle que vous êtes chef produit au
sein du groupe airwell c'est la fin de
ce numéro merci de l'avoir suivi on se
quitte sur ces images du duod chez
Safran aerosystème à plaisir le principe
un collaborateur volontaire forme un duo
avec une personne en situation de
handicap objectif faire découvrir son
métier et faciliter l'inclusion les
images sont signées Julien Leroy à
bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]